this is a production of cornell
university
oh here we go good
um this is what brussels sprouts look
like
brussels sprouts were invented in
belgium and the main capital of belgium
is called brussels
and that's where they get their name and
it's a good to remember that because
belgium is in the north
western portion of europe where you have
where a lot of fertile soil right on the
on the seashore it's a maritime climate
that is characterized by long
and relatively cool summers with
frequent rain
and a long mild winter very long days in
the summertime it's quite a bit farther
north than where we are right now
and
to find similar kinds of conditions
relatively mild growing conditions in
north america you really have to go to
coastal care for california parts of
washington state northern washington
state coastal areas of oregon
and also in the winter time
in mexico
the baja peninsula and some of the
higher
elevations
in mexico and central mexico
when we're talking about climate on the
east coast we're really talking about
continental climate so our summers are
short
but very intense and things can warm
very quick in the spring as you know
there's a quick period of a lot of heat
and and stress
either torrential rain or no rain at all
and then before you know it it's winter
time again
if we take a look at
the
fertility requirements for brussels
sprouts here you have an interesting
slide and we're going to spend a little
bit of time on this slide you can see
the fertility recommendations there for
phosphorus for nitrogen potash
then we have
sulfur
mexican crops need quite a bit of sulfur
some magnesium and some calcium
and these are listed here in kilograms
or hectare which is pretty much the same
thing as pounds per acre so you can
pretty much translate that directly and
then what you see in
this is a slide from northern europe and
then plant pretty early in april already
we may not be able to get on the ground
yet in april and may have to delay it a
little bit but for all practical
purposes you see the crop progression
and you can see the plant development
from planting all the way until
mid-summer and then late summer as we go
along here
you can see a crop progression like this
plants reach the full height under ideal
conditions by mid to late summer and
then the sprouts begin to develop and
you can see that the sprouts
develop from the bottom on up going up
the stem as the season progresses
and you also see that the leaves begin
to fall off
you can see that phosphorus is taken up
in early part of the season to form a
strong root system
of course but once the root system is
established not much more phosphorus is
needed most of the potassium is taken up
early in the season that has to do with
the development of the stock and the
development of the plants so basically a
lot of the pottery is used to
develop
the structure that is called ultimately
support the brussels sprouts and then
nitrogen uptake
is progressively increases but then
levels off and then trails off towards
the end of the season and i'm going to
spend a little bit of time on this slide
because it's important to understand why
this is
you can see that nitrogen uptake is
pretty strong while the plant is
developing but once the plant has
developed its maximum height
it begins to reallocate its resources
from leaf production to sprout
production
and you can see that a lot of the
nutrients that are used to produce the
sprouts are basically nutrients that
have been redistributed out of the
leaves and into the developing sprouts
if there is enough nitrogen in the soil
you should be able to let this plant
continue to develop and it will develop
just like this
if however for some reason
you have a wet summer like we had this
last year and you lose a lot of the
nutrients you may be short of nitrogen
at that point
and what then is going to happen is the
plant is going to cannibalize the lower
sprouts redistribute the nutrients out
of the lower sprouts to feed the top
sprouts
in an other situation for instance if
you have too much fertility
too much fertility is going to stimulate
leaf growth and it's going to prevent
some of these lower leaves from starving
and it's going to keep those leaves
green so if you have too much fertility
you have a plant that has a lot of
leaves on it and they have to really dig
around in there to find the sprouts if
you don't have enough fertility then
you're going to see that the lower
sprouts are going to lose quality
because
they lose nutrients the tissues become
weak and they become much more
susceptible to invasion by pests and
diseases
my computer is a little slow to respond
sorry so we here we have a
depiction of an ideal situation you get
rapid growth in the first half of the
season so you need to really fertilize
the sprouts quite heavily
at the first part of the season so
basically front load most of your
fertilizer and then keep a little bit of
nitrogen for side resting later on in
the season
the plants should reach their maximum
height towards the second half of the
season
the fertility should be mostly used up
by the end of the season so that the
nutrients that are in the leaves can be
redistributed to form the sprouts but
then the leaves should die off and fall
off so that you have these nice naked
stems with nice green and not funky
sprouts and then we'll talk a little bit
about
topping of the plants towards the end of
the presentation
this is the ideal situation and you can
see exactly what is happening exactly
what we showed in the slide i showed you
a little bit earlier
you can see nice straight stems
nice even distribution of sizing of
sprouts all the way up and down the stem
the sprouts are nice and green there are
no yellow spots except for this one over
here they can begin to develop a little
yellow wing so
but you can also see that the leaves
have basically been used up the leaves
have fallen down to the bottom of the
ground these sprouts have been topped
and so pretty much the top of the stem
is gone most of the top leaves are gone
and you have nice development of the
sprouts all the way to the top this is
an ideal situation
but
we are not in belgium and our situation
for growing brussels products is not
ideal
the reality of the situation is is that
we have
heat stress in mid-summer and when it's
really hot the brussel sprouts don't
like it they don't grow anymore they may
not necessarily wilt but
they will not grow anymore either that
means that you get loss of production
the stems are going to be shorter
water stress is going to lead to calcium
deficiency same as you see in blossom
end rot in peppers and tomatoes for
instance that will ultimately
result in internal breakdown of tissues
of the of the sprouts
internal tip burn or sometimes some
external tip burn and the crop maturity
could be delayed
when there is no growth that means that
the top bud is dormant and is no longer
exerting apical dominance and that means
that if there is any kind of regrowth so
you get a little bit cooler weather or
you get a bit of rain that means that
the bottom sprouts are basically have
gained their independence at that point
and they began begin to
start sizing up while the top sprouts
haven't even started to developing yet
so you get uneven sizing that means
oversized sprouts at the bottom and
undersized sprouts at the top the under
oversized products are over mature too
quickly
they become weak they begin to stretch
they become susceptible to invasion by
diseases etc and then of course what we
learned in 2021 we had a wet summer the
loss of nutrients towards the end of the
season results in a weakened crop that
is also more susceptible to diseases
so what do you do to avoid some of these
stresses well irrigate mid-summer if you
can
sometimes you can avoid somebody's
stressful period by planting a little
earlier and making sure you get lots of
growth on the plant before stress comes
in usually in july
use varieties that are relatively
vigorous so
they they can they can make that extra
growth and can grow through some of the
stress
but which right is best for you depends
a little bit on your particular
situation
and you'll have to experiment with
varieties a little bit to find out which
variety has the ready figure for your
ground and has the right maturity for
your market
and how much fertilizer should you use
well the recommendations that i showed
you earlier really based on ideal
situations in belgium and that means
that the crop is never stressed and is
always growing so therefore is very
productive but then also takes up more
nutrients i think the numbers that i
show here are a little
reduction by about 30 or so of of the
top numbers that i gave you earlier
if you have good ground and you have
good irrigation and you have a
productive year they're probably going
to need more fertilizer if it's a
stressful year they're probably not
going to need as much
that makes sense i think
here's a little study that we did in our
farm in geneva where we look at the
effect of planting time and we planted
three different varieties the vino marta
and dagon from left to right the reno
marta dagon with a couple of guard rows
of franklin you can see the green guard
roads of franklin on the outside and we
planted them in may june and july and
then we evaluated towards end of october
beginning november
and what do we see
at harvest time we see in the may
planting that we have good
sprout development the plants are
beginning to look a little tired as you
would like the like to see in brussels
sprouts some of them are over mature but
we have good yield here
if you look at the planting that was
made in june
the plants are healthier looking a
little bit more upright
the top sprouts are still a bit small in
this planting but
the
stalks have reached good length so we're
not altogether unhappy about this
planting
and then you see what happened in july
these plants look perfectly happy but
there's no sprouts in them because they
were planted right in this stressful
period and they stood around standing
doing nothing for about six weeks before
the weather got cooler and they started
to grow
the sprouts are really nice and clean
but
there's hardly any sprouts there they're
low yield and here's a close-up
this is a variety that has
medium medium vigor i would say decent
decent to medium vigor this is dagon
planted in may june and july you can see
the lower sprouts are developing very
nicely the lower leaves are beginning to
fall off the middle sprouts are
beginning to develop the top sprouts
are still not quite there
but if you looked at later planting you
see fewer sprouts at the top
decent
sprocket development at the bottom
decent quality middle sprouts a little
smaller and in july just a few sprouts
at the bottom nothing in the middle and
nothing at the top
so
from this picture you say may june is
probably a good time for planting
brussels sprouts in our area this is
marte this is a little bit stronger
variety a little bit more vigor
and also good field holding you can see
the same story here very good sprout
development and beginning to fill nicely
at the top already from a may planting
and the lower sprout quality is still
acceptable
uh june a little bit behind in
development but because of good vigor it
grew to the stress fairly well
and so the difference between a may and
june planting is not that big but
definitely a july planting not enough
yield not enough sprout filled at the
top
there's another variety this is the vino
very popular in california but it
doesn't work for us very well because
it's not very very vigorous and so it's
very susceptible to stress and you can
see that a little bit here it needs a
lot of time uh to be able to do
something through a stressful summer may
planting is good the june planting
very small sprouts just barely beginning
to develop and remember we're in
november now so
not much time to make sprouts anymore
and july is basically
hardly anything there
this is what you see
in a wet summer this is what we talked
about before you can see that the lower
leaves have fallen off and they're
laying on the ground here and
those nutrients have been redistributed
to form these sprouts but it was a wet
summer a lot of water a lot of the
nutrients have washed out and while the
top sprouts are beginning to fill
the nutrients that are needed to fill
those top sprouts don't come from the
ground anymore but come from the lower
sprouts and that makes those lower
sprouts much more susceptible to attack
by fungi and in some cases bacteria but
altenaria is quite often what you see in
these lower sprouts so you take this to
a phytopathologist and they say yeah
it's alternaria so we're always worried
about spray and fungicides to keep these
lower sprouts
clean but really what is happening here
is that these sprouts have run out of
fertility and you can know you know it
yourself if you have a crop that is
hungry
it gets very susceptible to disease and
there's no amount of spraying to keep
that crop going it really needs to be
fed
you can see in this same field
that
that was managed a little bit
differently there was some early
planting there were some later plantings
you can see the same thing this is an
early planting of dagen and you can see
that the lower sprouts are beginning to
get
ugly whereas this is a later planting so
that basically means that
even though some of the fertility washed
out a lot of the fertility
that was taken up by these plants early
on in the season was still available for
these plants so these plants basically
had a little bit more feed
and
therefore went from a slightly later
planting
suffered less from nutrient loss
and provided a better crop
this is a very new variety of our silvia
similar kind of a story an early
planting lower sprouts
decent holding up fairly well on sylvia
but still beginning to see a little bit
of quality issues whereas a later
planting
just was able to take advantage of
whatever fertility was still left in
that field but this is basically a
situation where the growth did not top
dress
and you can see that the
the lack of fertility especially in
early plantings leads to quality issues
let's talk about some of these quality
issues
some of the quality issues that you see
that we call it you know the funkiness
of the lower sprouts
is a result of a physiological disorder
tip burn
calcium deficiency
also called summer frost sometimes
and is caused by environmental stress so
you have water transport to some of the
leaves but not to the young developing
tissues leading to calcium deficiency
and also things like uneven growth can
make development of the sprouts
as premature as we talked about the
lower sprouts can become
developed too quickly and become
over-mature
and then you what you see then in these
weak tissues that alternaria invades
these tissues but alternary is not the
primary cause it is environmental stress
it's fertility stress it's uneven growth
so what to do about that is to make sure
that you can even out the growth and
alleviate some of that stress by either
drainage
when the field is too wet or irrigate
when the field is too dry and side rest
of nitrogen when you see that the
quality of the lower sprouts is
beginning to decline
and you can see here exactly what i mean
this is the top sprouts of the plant the
top sprouts are where the plant invests
most of its energy it's this is the
young the youth this is the future so
invest in the future and these sprouts
are actively growing and getting all the
nutrients they need at the expense of
other structures in the plant and the
other structures in the plant are often
the lower sprouts so i took some of the
lower sprouts from that same plant i
tried to clean them up a little bit but
you can see that i had to do quite a bit
of trimming
to get the outer leaves that are dirty
off of there and even after some hard
trimming these
sprouts are not nearly as as good and as
clean you can also see they're beginning
to open up a little bit
and that there's some problems
associated with that as well
a close-up look of some funky sprouts at
the bottom the stem i think most of you
who have grown brussels sprouts over the
over the course of the past several
years have seen some of these things and
have wondered what to do about that and
you can see another close-up snails get
in there sometimes but you can also see
yellowing of these tissues that
basically means they're nitrogen
efficient
nitrogen is being taken out of these
sprouts to feed the upper sprouts the
young sprouts
and what you can see at these lower
sprouts is that if you get uneven growth
that the sprouts begin to elongate
so
apical dominance is lost that means that
the lower sprouts are going to make
their own stems and you can see that
they're fully prepared to do that and
they're even fully prepared to make
mixed stems that have little sprouts on
them because after all that's what
brussels sprouts do don't they
and then a close-up of that is you can
see exactly what happens when these
sprouts begin to elongate they get loose
and you can also see that because these
little rapidly use these leaves that go
over the top of the brussels sprout as
the sprout begins to stretch they get
detached from the stem that means that
they die
and of course dying tissues again become
very susceptible to separatic fungi like
alton area then you see this nice little
aphid that's walking around over here
this event is for on a little walk
because he has a beautiful home in this
brussels sprouts nicely protected and
it's important to keep sprouts nice and
tight and to not deny these aphids an
opportunity to hide from enemies and
from insecticides
this is an extreme case at the very
bottom of this brussels sprout plant way
over mature these brussels sprouts are
beginning to bloom out and and butt out
you see a close-up here of this brussels
sprout in my hand and you can see that
this nice little stem with a crown of
little leaves and little mini sprouts on
the side if you can find somebody that
gives you top dollar for mini sprouts
maybe this is a way to save your income
but i think we all realize that this is
pretty much a lost cause
then we can see what the effect is of
summer frost this internal calcium
deficiency that leads to internal tiburn
you see these kinds of things and those
of you with growing cabbages do
recognize this the tip burn can be a
real problem especially during hot and
dry summers
not always necessarily obvious from the
outside but once you cut the cabbage
open or if you cut the sprouts open you
can see that
quite easily
similar to blossom end rot in tomatoes
and peppers and i'm sure most of you are
familiar with that story it's not
calcium deficiency in the soil it's just
a lack of water to help this distribute
that calcium from the soil to the young
developing tissues and when those
tissues become calcium deficient of
course they prone to collapse when
there's a little bit of stress and
that's exactly what you see here
uh it can be internal but can also be
external and here's a nice example of
what you call that summer frost it
almost looks like you know this tip burn
on the outside and you can see that
altenary is already going to town on
these tip burnt leaves
this is the outside of the sprout this
is one layer in still happening this is
two layers in this is three layers in
and then
you have to really get into the middle
of the sprout before you get something
clean but again
this product is not marketable
what you then sometimes also see is that
you get some of these tissues that are
weakened but can can become
susceptible or bacteria can invade them
so now you get these some of these
different or weakened tissues
soft rot bacteria get in there and then
you have a real mess this is this is not
pretty when this happens i hope it never
happens to you but if it does happen
at least you
have some indication that the croppers
may be just a little bit too stressed
during the the most stressful part of
the growing season and that then leads
to pictorial problems later on
we know that trips can be an issue in
brussels sprouts as well
here are some examples
not really sure what i can recommend to
prevent that from happening
some varieties clearly are a little bit
more susceptible than others
i don't see it too much but if i if you
do see it and you say boy this is really
too bad because the rest of the plant
was it was developing quite nicely and
then we do still still see some of these
uh
yeah this uh this this puckering that
that is the result of thrips feeding
now let's talk a little bit about
topping when to top
um
don't top until you're basically
you have a mar you have a market for
your brussels sprouts and you have a
customer that is ready to take about 10
days before you're ready to ship the
brussels sprouts you take the top out
and that allows the
last few sprouts at the very tip of the
plant
to grow a little bit more and that means
you get a little bit extra yield but
be careful that you don't top until you
are ready to sell because if you plant
too far ahead
you get this kind of a system
this
stuff that was stopped at the right time
you can see the top sprouts and
beginning to get some least size begin
to catch up to the size of the sprouts
that are down below here but very
quickly they will overshoot the size and
then
blow blowouts become bloomy because see
there is no top bud anymore so we have
these four or five brussels sprouts at
the top that are all fighting for
dominance and they're gonna try and make
a stem as quickly as they can and that
means basically even though you top to
get more size you're going to lose these
sprouts anyway because now they are too
big
brussels sprouts are much more
challenging to grow than kale
let me leave you with this image
imagine that you are
that you're driving around in the car
and you lose the brakes on the car
you're
not in a mood to walk home so you're
gonna try and make it home
in this car without brakes
what do you do
you give it just enough gas to keep up
the speed
but you don't want to go so fast that
you that you're going to get into a bad
accident you're going to slow down a
little bit and by the time the car
begins to slow down you give it a little
bit more gas to try to keep a moderate
speed
now you come up
to the driveway and you can
kind of take a look at the driveway as
this the
fertility of your soil if you have poor
soil you basically have a driveway that
goes uphill
if you want to get the car in the garage
you're going to have to give it a little
bit of gas or in this case the brussels
sprouts you're going to have to give
them a little more nitrogen to make sure
they make it to the end
and then you give them just enough so
that
they finish up just fine without making
too many leaves but also without the
sprouts turning yellow in other words
you're trying to get the car in the
garage with just enough gas to get there
if you have a level driveway that means
moderate fertility in your field
very easy does it you don't want to give
them too much utility doors because
still you
you could overchoose you can build up
too much speed or in this case brussels
sprouts you can make too many leaves if
you have a downhill driveway that means
that your ground is too fertile already
you're going to have to take out a few
fence posts maybe on the way to the
garage and try to slow down the car but
the likelihood is that you're going to
go right to the back wall in the garage
i hope that that image helps you a
little bit to think about how to grow
brussels sprouts brussels sprouts
good fertility in the beginning try to
avoid stressful conditions as much as
you can
fertilize them a little bit if it looks
like the quality of the lower sprouts is
going south on you don't fertilize so
much that the lower that the leaves
don't shed it's a real touchy
equilibrium
if you have a year where you have
a lot of water and a lot of nutrient
wash out it probably means you have to
side rest a little bit more aggressively
if you have a dry year where the plants
are a little bit stressed and not
growing so much you probably didn't lose
that much nutrients so you want to be
careful about not side dressing the
plant especially not during the time
when it's stressful because the plants
aren't taking anything up anyway and so
there will be plenty of fertility left
for these plants to finish off just fine
at the end of the season
but everybody's ground is different
every season is different and every
variety behaves a little bit differently
some varieties are early maturing some
varieties mature a little bit later some
varieties are more vigorous some
varieties have less bigger so it takes
several years to understand how a
variety grows and it takes several years
to figure out how to fertilize that crop
just so so that you end up with that
perfect brussels sprout in the very end
i hope that this was
educational for you
it's been certainly educational for us
at bijo to try to grow brussels sprouts
here in new york
every year that we do it we learn a
little bit more
and hopefully i'll get a chance to talk
to some of you and maybe you can relate
some of your experiences to me and we
can
continue to learn to grow how to grow
bodacious brussels sprouts together
thanks very much
thank you yarn emma did you see any um
questions in the chat
um we just have one about what the time
frame for late versus early planting was
in those pictures that were shown
um i think that was
yeah and if you could stop sharing your
screen uh chris could load up while you
answer that question
yeah
um the uh
the pictures that we showed
the grower was not entirely clear on
when they planted but they started
planting in
may and planted all the way through july
so i think some of these uh the early
plantings were probably maybe late made
planting the grove planted pretty much
every two weeks
and
so
the early planting was probably made in
early june and the later planting was
probably towards late june early july
but that was in pennsylvania so a little
slightly different situation as it was
here in new york
so brussels sprouts have an f word too
funky
yup
thanks
thank you yawn um all right so our
our our last presentation is going to be
a two-part between um chris smart and
myself and and chris smart as a cornell
vegetable plant pathologist she is a
treasure and a pleasure to work with i
really enjoyed working with her and
alternatively spot and head rot in
broccoli and she's gonna
this is a
very exciting disease to work with and
so she's gonna um start the presentation
and then i'm going to finish with um the
fungicide trial results
so chris whenever you are ready thank
you christy and thank you yan for
introducing alternaria and jan has
showed me samples and i say yep that's
alternaria
just just as he said i would
um so i always like to introduce the
people that do do the work that i'll be
talking about today and collin day
as well as uh he's the um research
associate lab member in lab manager in
my lab and hiroo bita who is a postdoc
in my lab are the folks that are
spearheading our alternaria project
i thought i'd give a quick overview
although i can shorten it up uh jan
showed you some really nice pictures um
alternative leaf spot in new york is
caused by uh fungus alternaria
brassacicola it's kind of a fun word to
say
um
has these uh especially when it's dry
outside you'll see these tan lesions
that are uh have that characteristic uh
concentric circle target look to them
and when you have humidity you get lots
and lots of dark deep dark black uh
spores on the leaves and uh this is uh
cabbage and up here i think that's
cauliflower many of you may remember i
had a student
a few years back that did a lot of
studies on alternaria breast circle and
cauliflower
the spores themselves are actually quite
heavy compared to other pathogen spores
so they can't blow in the wind very far
they blow short distances
and they tend to start on the lower
leaves as jan said
alternaria likes that
older dead or dying tissue it's where it
really can take hold and then it starts
on those lower leaves and the rain will
splash it up higher in the plant in
order to get the spores you have to have
either free water rain or um high
humidity and uh a warmest warmer
temperature at least between 65 and 85
fahrenheit uh we tend to see this later
in the season although um uh recently it
has shown up
earlier than than say i saw it 10 years
ago
the spores of the pathogen themselves
can be on seed
commonly found on debris in the soil and
it will also ta attack uh cruciferous
weeds
so i thought i'd show some early lesions
this is a broccoli leaf that has some
tiny specks on that are early
alternation and this is actually from a
transplant i'd say
every year i get some transplants that
will have little black spots on like
this this is what alternaria spots look
like on a transplant but let me just say
there are several other pathogens that
look exactly like this and in order to
really figure out what that lesion is on
the transplant i always have to isolate
it's really hard to to determine small
uh dark brown speck on transplant it's
hard to figure out which pathogen that
might be
so
uh here is a close-up image of that
alternaria leaf spot showing
that
target-like lesion and i always show
this picture because uh it was from one
of my research trials and you can see uh
the
control pesticide residue on the leaf
and um
the alternate area was unfazed that was
not because the alternative was
resistant to that particular product but
it was rather that the product was a pr
was not applied early enough to really
nip that alternary in the bud and once
it takes off it's really hard to control
in terms of host range um i i need to to
visit yon's trials because he had some
uh nice pictures of alternaria on
brussels sprouts i need to update my my
photo gallery on
um
we as i will talk about have spent a lot
of time on broccoli uh this summer
uh head rot on broccoli will you'll see
uh part of the of the broccoli head
that's not growing as well
and if you take a closer look you'll see
the the dark lesions
and then once you have that dark lesion
you actually start to get just a general
rot on the on the broccoli head uh
you'll see it on kale
as i said it's a it's a huge problem on
cauliflower as well but it it will
attack all brassicas um as listed on the
right hand side of the slide
so christie and i are part of an uh
fairly new project
um
the official name of the project is
control alt delete
for those of you who uh use a pc you'll
know that we have to use control alt
delete to turn on our computer every day
um
but the idea there was to uh
control alternaria and with any luck at
all we would like to delete it
uh the project ran runs from october of
2020 maybe september of 2020 through
august of 24.
and it's a joint project between georgia
virginia and new york where we have
field trials and then um a scientist in
connecticut who is doing uh fungicide
sensitivity and um pathogen
genotype diversity
so um
in addition to the diversity and
fungicide sensitivity uh we did a
variety trial that i'll be talking about
today we looked at nitrogen rates uh
similar to what jan discussed um and
then we had an overhead irrigation trial
which to be fair christie and i
when we were talking to our colleagues
from virginia and georgia said you know
overhead irrigation trial it's probably
going to rain
but they're like oh come on let's do the
overhead irrigation trial
we had never had so much rain during a
trial as in our overhead irrigation
trial uh so
we were supposed we were looking at the
difference between morning midday and
evening irrigation the idea being if you
irrigate in the morning the plants will
dry out during the day and you'll have
less disease compared to if you irrigate
in the evening um you know
at six o'clock or so before sundown then
the plants you're extending that time of
leaf wetness which is necessary for
alternaria to take a hold
well uh our plants
when we when we planted
it was a beautiful day the soil was
exactly correct and then it rained and
rained and rained and and colin put down
this beautiful irrigation system that
was only used on the day we planted we
never used it again the rest of the
season so our irrigation trial uh was
rained out and then we did fungicide
trials uh that that christie will
discuss
so i thought i would show you a picture
of the pathogen and culture
it really does have a dark black velvety
look to it
um
every isolate
that we collected this summer as part of
the diversity trial haroot
isolated 121
from 121 different samples four fields
um in different parts of the state
you can see this is a very severely
infected leaf here
all of those isolates were alternaria
brassacola
interestingly and and all the isolates
that have been tested to date uh were
sensitive uh to azoxy strobin the active
ingredient in in quadrus that many folks
would use um
to control alternaria uh that's the only
fungicide that has been tested so far
and only 10 of our isolates from this
year have been tested the complete panel
has not yet been tested so we'll have
more information on that later
in addition to testing for fungicide
sensitivity we'll be looking at pathogen
diversity to see if how different the
pathogen is
across the within a field and across
different sites both within new york as
well as virginia and georgia
that'll be really interesting to know we
don't know a lot about um the
reproductive strategies of this pathogen
so is it exclusively asexual is there
sexual reproduction
and and what is that doing is that
increasing our chances of getting uh of
of losing fungicide sensitivity
in georgia
they
found isolates that were not alternary
of brassicala but were a different
species alton area japonica and what the
group found was that those isolates that
species is naturally
less sensitive to azoxy strobin than the
alternaria brassacola so um we'll learn
more about that we have not found that
yet in new york but we will continue to
to take samples and and follow that
closely
because we want to make sure that
when something is being applied to a
field that's going to be effective
the other thing that my lab has done is
looked at
the host range of these 121 isolates so
each isolate was inoculated onto
broccoli cabbage kale collard and
cauliflower and
what herod has found is that across all
of the isolates broccoli and collards
are the two most susceptible
um
uh
and cabbage of the isolates we had was
the least susceptible but
all of the host all of those are hosts
and interestingly the other thing she
found was that you can sort of see it in
this this picture these are four
different isolates all inoculated onto a
small
uh broccoli leaf
and you can see this isolate has really
taken off whereas you don't see the
alternaria quite as much on the other
isolates yet and what she has found is
that there are some isolates of those
121 that are much more aggressive than
others in fact she had two of those 121
isolates that did not cause disease
which is interesting since she isolated
it from a plant that had a lesion so
we're really
digging into those data now she's just
collecting the last of it and um i think
that will be really informative to see
what the differences are between the
more aggressive and the less aggressive
isolates
um so for our field trials as i said uh
we planted in may and uh
we
we used uh the the plant the planter
thomas thomas bjorkman got a beautiful
broccoli planter that we were able to
use we planted double rows uh
we broke our trials into 20 feet 20-foot
plots and we had four reps of each
treatment and that's calling there
making sure everything goes in smoothly
and as i said he had the irrigation all
set and then it rained and rained and
rained
we inoculated we planted in very late
june we inoculated with alternaria we're
on our research farm um so we inoculated
in early early july and
we i think actually uh haroot and i
inoculated on july 4th
and
on july 5th it it was started to to
rain you know not heavily just we had
light rain and and fog and
you know 65 to 70 degree weather for
like a month
and
we had rapid i call it rapid and severe
disease
so this was a broccoli leaf i think this
was
maybe 10 10 days to two weeks after we
inoculated one of the things i really
noticed on the broccoli was that the
stem lesions shown in this middle
picture
we had so many stem lesions we had more
stem lesions than leaf lesions and those
stem lesions would just have millions of
canadia on them and i don't know if that
was a function of
the the cultivar of broccoli that we
used or the isolate um but i'll be
looking more into that too just so many
stem lesions and um we had severe uh
headlight as well
so we did do a nitrogen fertilizer trial
uh based on the amount of nitrogen in
the soil test uh we were
we were assuming the recommended rate
for our field would be 120 pounds per
acre um so that was our 100
nitrogen rate in this table here so we
have uh the percent nitrogen from
recommended from 150
to 125 percent the recommended rate
which would have been 120 pounds uh 75
and 50
and then we calculated the amount of
disease uh or audpc but you can just
think of this as the amount of disease
the bigger the number the more disease
on both the leaf and the head
and uh as you can see the lowest rate of
nitrogen you know the plants were just
not as vigorous not as healthy and um
we had
the highest amount of disease and uh
while it was not statistically
significant uh on the amount of leaf
lesions for the head blight uh it was
there was statistically more disease on
the heads with the least amount of
nitrogen um so
i do think that the data in in this
trial were impacted by the amount of
rain we had i think um there perhaps was
more disease in in all of the treatments
because the nitrogen um when we side
dressed it it was so wet the nitrogen
was washed away but clearly
the least amount of nitrogen
was
[Music]
making the plant more susceptible to the
alternative
and then uh finally before i turn it
over to christy um i'll talk briefly
about our variety trial we had the same
27 broccoli trials broccoli varieties in
georgia virginia and in new york and we
planted this one in august
we didn't
we were worried about having all of the
other trials plus
the variety trial out in the field at
the same time so we planned this late
season
i think this year we won't do that we'll
plant everything earlier um because
these plants we planted them they ended
up in the field so late that they never
really got uh decent heads
um again we use the double rows uh 20
feet per plot and four reps of of each
of the varieties and heru and i rated
them uh six times we did not inoculate
this because we planted it in the field
right next to where our early season
trial was and there was just so much
inoculum that everything was immediately
uh inoculated once we put it into the
field
so then i thought we had had a lot of
rain prior to august but uh the days
after we planted our variety trial it
actually rained so much that our field
flooded out and you can see
um this just freshly transplanted
broccoli uh that
they drowned and and many of the plants
in the left side picture here did drown
we lost we lost some reps because of
that
we're hoping for less rain or more
well-drained soil
in 2022
so i i didn't include all 27 varieties
in this table
because it gets too well i think it gets
too busy
actually in new york um colin was really
interested in looking at a sprouting
broccoli cultivar so we included one of
those and it turned out that that
cultivar had the least amount of disease
but i i don't know if it's if it's
because
that cultivar is actually has more
resistance or if it's something about
the maturity of that sprouting uh
sprouting broccoli cultivar um that that
when you know when the plants got
inoculated it just wasn't as uh
susceptible to disease so there's
there's more to be learned there
but the other cultivars that and this
was fairly consistent across locations
um
montebello asteroid diplomat and bell
star
tended to have less disease now if you
look at the little numbers above the
bars you'll see that there's an a
um on on diplomat and bell star and i
will say for diplomat we lost two of the
four replicates in the great flood of
22. um
so there is that um but
our our most susceptible cultivars were
green magic and and emerald star and as
i said we're going to be doing this
again this year and um
hopefully um
our environment will be such that uh
we'll be able to look more closely at um
differences in susceptibility on the
head
and um have have more data for you this
time next year
and with that i am handing it off to
christy to talk about uh fungicide
trials
i am very excited to share with you
fresh research results from
five fungicide trials that were
conducted in new york last growing
season in 2021 in both conventional and
organic fungicides
so in addition to the control all delete
project i also had some funding from ir4
to look at a a pipeline product i'm also
going to share results from a trial that
ethan grenberg and tressa russonek did
funded by the hudson valley food hub and
again acknowledging my technicians emma
and sarah and also i did an on-farm
trial um with kalutz farm in kendall
or the trial was in holly but the
growers are from kendall
so these are the treatments that were
evaluated in
in these trials
um they included bravo which is a
multi-site mode of action
m zero five quadras uh frack eleven
switch is a nine and a twelve a whole
bunch of sevens um preaxer maravon luna
sensation luna experience miravus prime
endura and fontellus
take note fontellos is not labeled in
new york
but it is in other states so it's in our
trial as well luna experience is not
labeled on head brassicas but it's
labeled some other brassicas maravon's
not labeled on brass because it's sister
fungicide pre-axar is
i also looked at effect 21 a new corteva
pipeline product
several frac threes inspire super
quadris top top guard i also put in um
sevia which is a brand new frac 3 from
bsf it's not labeled in brassicas but
just another active ingredient
and very pleased that we had seven
different organic products belonging to
different
um frac groups or different having
different mode of action
um out of these microthial disperse
um it's labeled on brassicas but it's
not specifically labeled on altenaria
so i'm going to start with the
conventional fungicides we had three
trials
so the one that chris smart did
at agritech in the summer the broccoli
was planted on may 26 sprays
from june 28 to july 6 with the harvest
july 26-29 artificial inoculation which
you previously described very severe
pressure then i set up a trial on farm
and holly this was in a
conventional commercial
large broccoli field with klutz um the
field was planted july 5th i sprayed
august 5th to september 12th the harvest
was from september 3rd to september 12th
i was relying on a natural inoculation
and
i sprayed and i sprayed and i sprayed
and after the fifth spray i still had
not seen disease i went out to collect
the steaks and by golly disease had
finally come in as they were harvesting
the trial so i went out and sprayed one
more time so those last two sprays five
and six probably went towards
controlling the disease i rated that as
low pressure
uh then
i had a i had a trial with at agra tech
in the fall so this is the same timing
as chris put the variety trial in um so
it was planned august 4th sprayed august
25th
to october 25th harvest october 20th to
november 2nd relying on natural inoculum
but of course it's right beside her
festering um
her festering fungicide child from the
summer so it ended up having moderate to
severe pressure
um emerald crown was a variety that we
were using except the growers were using
emerald easter i should say eastern
crown
which is a little bit more tolerant to
alton area and i use dynamic chris is
not using any adjuvants and we're
spraying pretty much on a weekly
schedule five to nine times depending on
the trial
we'll take a look at the results so this
is chris's trial summer trial at
agritech in geneva what we are looking
at is percent alternative leaf spot
severity at the final assessment so
looking at the plot the what percentage
of the foliage is covered in alton area
the untreated 33
that's pretty high
um and then all of my plots are
organized in order from the best
performing treatment to the worst and i
flank off what's not significantly
different from the best treatment and
then i flank off what's not
significantly different from the worst
treatment so we'll take a look at the
best in trial they're all frack threes
and frack sevens inspire super
pre-access mirvis prime quadrus talk
luna sensation fontellus
with the exception of chop guard a frac
3 and endura a frack 7 that are kind of
in this middle of the pack category
better than bravo better than the
untreated not quite as good as a front
runner
i'm not sure why this active ingredient
is not as good as some of the best
performing ones um
with respect to the phrax sevens endura
is an active ingredient that um when
when a pathogen is developing resistance
this tends to be the first one to slip
so i hope that we're not seeing the very
beginning of fungicide resistance but
that's what this project is all about
um is to keep to be monitoring that very
very closely here's quadrus chris is
using the high rate 15 and a half
um here's quadrus top
no significant difference between the
two
here's bravo 42
reduction in leaf severity better than
the untreated all of the other
fungicides are better than bravo
and switch um coming in the same as
quadras
so now we'll go to holly
and um
so sorry i mentioned i had low
um pressure so i i couldn't it was
really tricky for us to estimate percent
severity
so we actually just counted lesions
so we had 88 lesions per plant in the
untreated you can see everything
significantly reduced the number of
lesions on the leaves our front runners
frack three and sevens again inspire
super quadrus top luna sensation maravon
preaxer and mirvis prime
um except for the new frax3 from bsf
sevia
um significantly not as good as inspire
super and quadrus top
still having activity here's where um
quadras alone middle of the pack
um not as good as a front runner
definitely better than an untreated and
bravo this is the lower the lower rate
the 11 ounce rate um which was
significantly not as good as quadrus
talk which is along the lines of what i
found in my 2018 trial here's bravo
better than the untreated 71 percent
control not as good as a front runner
not as good as quadrus switch coming in
again very close to quadras and then
here's that fract 21 that i tried um
it's in line with bravo
so now let's take a look at head rot how
do how good do we do it keeping the rod
out of the heads because at the end of
the day that's what it's all about so
this is chris smart's trial in geneva
this is percent
head severity 30 the untreated has um 37
you can see all of the treatments
reduced head severity by a lot however
still 100 of the heads were unmarketable
because they all had at least one lesion
and i i wonder um
if stress came into play to some extent
with this it um because there's an
interaction between stress and
alternaria as jan demonstrated with the
brussels sprouts the same thing can
occur in broccoli so even if we have
excellent fungicide programs
you can't fix a stress problem with
fungicides i guess what i'm trying to
say
um no the front runners frack seven and
three um with exception of quadrus and
11 is right up there with the sevens and
threes uh bravo significantly better
than nothing 87 reduction in severity
not as good as any of the other
fungicides middle of the pack switch
endura and fontellus
here we're back in holly in the growers
trial
here i'm evaluating actual percent head
rod so even though the disease only came
in at the very very end i still had 22
percent of those heads that were
unmarketable
um here's the facts threes and sevens
quadrus top inspire super uh preaxer
mirvis prime or front runners here's
luna sensation maravon a little more
middle of the pack and sevia that basf
frack three not significantly different
from the untreated here's quadrus
um i'm using the low rate again um this
is this
this is quarters is not significantly
differently untreated but it's also not
significantly different than the best
treatment there's a lot of variability
in this trial um but numerically we're
talking about 46 percent reduction
compared to a 100 percent so starting
with the low rate of quadrus i'm seeing
more of a separation between quadrus and
quadrus taught here's frack 21 not
different than an untreated bravo middle
of the pack switch up with the front
runners
here's the
the ir4 trial that i conducted in geneva
this is um alton area leaf spot severity
at the end of the season in the in the
moderate to high pressure trial so 18 in
the untreated and i wanted to show you
how good luna experienced this is a
seven and a three ninety three percent
reduction um quadrus top 55 halfway
there that's the low rate um but what i
wanted to point out here with the frac
21
um product so this is a high rate
without an adjuvant 22 control better
than nothing but not great now add just
a little bit of dynamic and adjuvant
i've i've
um increased the control i've doubled
the control reduced the amount of um
alternate relief spot severity by half
and here is the half rate with an
adjuvant which is as good as a high rate
without an adjuvant so i think this is a
really good illustration of how
adjuvants may be helpful
particularly with fungicides that have
trans laminar or systemic activity that
need to get into the plant so that's
your freck 3 7 9 11
um
and then also as you know
brassicas have very waxy cuticles and i
think the adjuvants can help
help stay on help them stay on the leaf
a little bit better and some of the
fungicides are formulated very well with
adjuvants already in them but just
something for you to consider
so here's a visual of chris's trial at
harvest so this is the 33 36 percent of
the leaf foliage covered in alternary
and the untreated here's one of her best
treatments i think something like an
inspire
super and you can just see how it can do
really go a long way in cleaning up this
disease under very high pressure
this is the growers field in holly so
you can see some in the alternate area
some spots on the upper canopy leaves
the heads are starting to rot and here's
luna's sensation a frack three or sorry
a frac seven
just cleaning up the upper canopy leaves
keeping the heads clean
and here's my trial at the ir4 trial the
fall trial at agritech the untreated
this actually ended up with 85 rotten
heads um and you can see the lower frame
leaves are turning yellow you can see
the spots and here's that luna
experience that three and seven in the
same combination just spectacular shiny
and new when these fungicides are
working well they are they're fantastic
so here's the lineup of what you have
for conventional fungicides in new york
um i've listed them according to frat
groups so you've got bravo the m5
quadratus 11. so in the past we were
really holding off on recommending um
quadrus and the fact 11s because we were
suspicious that they were developing
resistance as chris let you know earlier
we have not detected that yet and as you
as i showed you from our trial results
they do appear to have activity and
they're working um so we're going to go
ahead and recommend them again there's a
lot of generics this might be one of the
more affordable fungicide options you
have
um switch is a 9 and a 12.
there's a bunch of sevens belonging to
different subclasses some of those are
are premixes with 11s um mirvis prime's
a premix with a 12 from switch and then
you've got
inspire super quadrage top and
top guard
um quarters and switch and inspire super
have generics so there may be some more
affordable options on the market i've
also listed the rating for risk of
fungicide resistance take note that the
11s and 7s are medium high to high risk
these are the ones that you want to be
very mindful of not overusing and
abusing or this pathogen will likely
develop resistance and as we've shown
you right now they are working very very
well
um i've included the pre-harvest
interval flagging the zero or one days
to harvest so these are the products you
can use while you're harvesting um three
of the frax sevens are restricted use
and there's the only one that is not so
if you don't have a spray license these
ones would not be available to you and
then a relative ranking of the control
so the frac sevens are excellent the
frack threes inspire super and quarters
top are excellent endura and chop guard
are very good
bravo is mediocre quadrus and switch are
good and then i've also flagged which
ones have activity against downy mildew
and which ones don't
so our recommendations for altenaria are
to spray fungicides preventatively
before ultinary establishes itself chris
said it's much easier to get ahead of it
than try to catch it the lower frame
leaves can serve as inoculum for the
heads and if you've got lesions on upper
canopy leaves it they can literally run
down the leaves onto the head
bravo is a good choice when disease
pressure is low if you're in high
disease conditions the canopy has filled
in aeration is reduced leaf wetness is
prolonged if you're scouting broccoli at
two o'clock in the afternoon and you're
getting wet
um it's probably conditions that are
favorable for disease especially if it's
known to occur in the area so that's the
time when you want to get out you're
very good to excellent fungicides and
run them right through harvest because
it's all about keeping the alton area
out of the heads
the use of the highest label rates is a
very good idea for resistance management
and i demonstrated the 15 ounces versus
the 11 ounces of quadrus that we were
getting better control with the higher
rate
um all of the fungicides except bravo
are at some risk for alternaria
developing fungicide resistance so for
best management fund
best fungicide resistance management
practices do not apply more than one to
two applications per frac before
rotating to a different group that's
going to be labeled late on the label
we are recommending to try not to use
more than 2x per frac per crop
um
especially for the frax 7s and the 11s
and be mindful that you're a lot of
these are premixes and you have to be
managing both active both frac groups
and are both active or frat groups in
the premix
and
consider using an adjuvant
for the products with trans laminar or
systemic activity
save the products with zero or one days
to harvest to use during harvest
and note that many of the als fungicides
do not control down in mildew bravo will
give you good control the fracked
leavens mediocre if you need excellent
control of downy mildew orondis opti or
ultra and revis and procedio are
probably the best products and we
encourage you to design your fungicide
spray program ahead of time
so this is an example of a program
starting with bravo
until
canopy fill in and then for a four week
program assuming conditions are high
giving the best control options you can
with our best projects products we're
basically rotating threes and sevens
being mindful not to rack up too many
11's in here so i've only got two which
is why
i didn't um i didn't use luna sensation
here because i would have had three
elevens in a row and saving the ones
with the zero and one pre-harvest
intervals to the two during harvest
um the frac sevens are restricted use so
if you don't have your spray license
here's a another example of a program
okay moving on to
the um
organic trials
so
again uh chris smart did an organic
trial basically beside the conventional
trial in the summer at geneva
i just put some organic treatments in
the trial i had in holly on farm and
then i'm going to share results from a
trial that ethan grenberg and teresa
russenig did in the hudson valley
so they
were the trial was planted august 17th
harvest or sprayed between august 25th
and 11th harvested october 13th to 25th
they had low to moderate pressure they
were also using emerald crown and use
the um the adjuvant attach
so we'll take a look at some results so
this is chris smart's trial we're
looking at
percent leaf severity at the end of the
season here's our untreated
here is um conventional fungicides a
frac seven and bravo and look what
organic product we have that is as good
as a conventional fungicide
landing at 60 control oh so 13 fluid
ounces this was very exciting to see
because truthfully i thought that
organic growers were
really going to be struggling
controlling alton area with the products
that they had available
the middle of the pack fungicides here
significantly better than the untreated
not as good as the front runner
microthial dispersed 40
control lifeguard um 31 control
um not significantly different than than
the untreated is co-side so this is a
copper
um
double nickel regalia not really doing
anything in this trial for altenaria
here's her headrot data so you can see
in black there the frax seven and the
bravo were highlighted and yep also at
13 fluid ounces
as good as a conventional fungicide
in the middle middle of the pack here
better than the untreated but not as
good as a front runner his lifeguard and
microphile disperse about 50 there not
not quite all the way um here's
co-side
not significantly done
different than the untreated also not
significantly different than light scar
to micro microthial disperse it looks
like it's really trying to work and it
actually in georgia the coppers were
working in their trials um double nickel
and then regalia
okay going to holly so i flagged in um
black there the fracks the frax sevens
and bravo
um and then i had oso at the 6.5 fluid
ounce rate so it's as good as bravo 81
control not as good as a front runner
frack seven i'm so curious if i would
have had that 13 fluid ounce rate i bet
you it would have been as good as a
seven
um
okay here's car here's copper in my
trial this was also cosine 3000 um the
same as copper 70 percent control and
carbonator uh two thirds of the way
there um definitely having some activity
on being able to reduce the lesion count
here's my head rot data
um so again in black are the frac sevens
and bravo here's oso again it's in line
with bravo two thirds of the way there
so instead of 22 rotten heads only seven
and here's copper
um
eighty percent control not different
than oso numerically it's giving us a
little bit better control only four
percent unmarketable heads um what's not
what didn't work was carbonator so it
was able to keep it off the foliage not
so good of a job keeping it out of the
heads
and then here's ethan's trial
in um hudson valley under moderate
pressure
so we're looking at altenary leaf
severity at harvest
13
in the in the untreated
um
we're seeing a lot of bars like this is
not looking like chris chris is in my
trials the control is not as good here
um but the only treatment that was
significantly better than the untreated
is also the six and a half ounce rate
with badge and so this section these
were all treatments that were regalia
lifeguards targets double nickel howler
dia
alter or sorry tank mixed with badge and
then this section is the same thing only
this time they're alternated with badge
so if you compare this as a group to
that as a group you can see the copper
when you're applying it every single
week versus every other week is having a
little bit of activity and here we see
that the high rate of oso alternating
with badge um has the least amount of
alternative although it's not
significant so why are they not getting
the efficacy that chris and i are well
this is not proven but one theory is
that a couple of the
spray intervals were 10 as many as 15
days apart and i think for these
biologicals that needs to be tightened
up to closer to seven maybe even tighter
when conditions are higher
so here is your lineup for organic um
fungicides
so we have oso
coside lifeguard carbonator all having
some activity regalia and double nickel
we are not recommending it those at this
time for alteneria
um
the best one of course is oh so good to
very good as good as a conventional
product
it also has the highest risk for
developing fungicide resistance it's not
in the same class as the sevens or the
elevens cosine and carbonator are low
not sure exactly what it is for
lifeguard all of them zero ph zero zero
days phi um there none of them are
restricted use
um so
it also is going to be expensive the low
rate is probably around 40 the high
rate's about 80.
we don't want you going out there and
spraying that six times in a row because
we don't want it to develop resistance
um but when pressure's low you can
probably be using co-side lifeguard
carbonator um and then when pressure is
high and you really want to keep the
heads clean that's when you focus on oh
so the higher the rate probably the
better the control
um just be very careful with adjuvants
and particularly copper
when temperatures are hot so just follow
the label for that um this is an area
i'd like to look into more uh this
summer
how if we can get some better activity
or the biologicals with the help of
adjuvants we'll see
so i know that was a lot of information
um
so to not blow your mind
um we do have a fungicide cheat sheet
for altenew leaf spot and head rot in
broccoli and other cold crops it's been
edited revised for the 2022 growing
season it's available on the cornell
website or sorry the cornell vegetable
program website got all the products the
rates the active ingredient the frat
groups the
relative risk of fungicide resistance
the phi whether it's restricted use crop
rotation restrict or sorry
not crop rotation um rotation restrict
rescript
restrictions maximum use rates what
crops it's labeled on relative rating
and what whether it has activity on
downy mildew and a step-by-step process
how you go about putting together your
spray program
alrighty i am going to stop sharing
and
if there's any
um questions in the chat or if anybody
has any questions for my presentation or
chris's presentation
um we do have a couple of questions um
first kevin would like to know if
participants will get a copy of the
materials for control of alternaria
so
that it should be covered in the in the
cheat sheet everything that's labeled
for alton area nebraska's in new york is
on that cheat sheet
okay i'll find a link to that and drop
it in the chat um
sure and then elizabeth wants to know do
you think sulfur has a place in an
organic rotation to improve economics
some of the charts looked like it
offered a bit of protection
yeah and we
we have so you're talking about
microstyle disperse i assume which is a
proper product um the only reason i did
not put that
in the cheat sheet is because it's not
specifically labeled for altenaria but
as we were talking about with cabbage
maggot and sweet midge sometimes you're
going to get incidental control when
you're
spraying for another pathogen
okay
um
well i i
if anybody is trying to drop out i would
i'd just like to encourage you to
sign out with the link because i have
another evaluation form there so you
need to sign out if you need your dc
credits but i would really welcome
getting some feedback
um from this session um it's certainly
not the same as walking into the
audience in person and talking to
everybody
i'm going to shut off my screen and i'll
be at my dining room table
i would also say that if anyone does
have an alternative outbreak this summer
we are collecting isolates we'll be
looking at diversity and fungicide
sensitivity so give us a call and we'll
come out and grab a bag of leaves
thank you
once again thank you to our sponsors our
arctic refrigeration and bijou seeds um
thank you to all of the speakers um
thank you all for joining us
joining us today on this wintery friday
afternoon
and
as always wish you nothing best but
nothing but the best for the 2022
growing season and you've paid your
money so you can attend any expo
sessions you want next week and the week
after there are several you can
load up on dc credits that is for sure
thanks everyone thank you everyone thank
you christy
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu